I hear that former Twitter CEO Dick
Costolo has been contributing some
insight to the silicon valley writers
room yeah did you ask if you hurt did
you ask my mother I don't know what
you're worth then there's no i'm not
asking whether that's true mr. Ryan so
here oh I think we're allowed to say
yeah he uh yeah he sits in our writers
room with us a couple days a week it's
great he bringing it yeah what is he
sure is well you know he has a comedy
background he did improv comedy in
Chicago way back in the day so um you
know comedy in the tech world rarely
cross paths as you might have seen if
you were at her panel just now oh but no
he's a he's a funny guy and you know
it's just great to be able to just you
know we're spinning stories coming up
with ideas and just go hey dick did
would this ever happen and I mean he you
know I mean it's essentially yes yeah
right so what's the most surprising
thing he's brought to the table hmm I
don't know I don't remember ever being
shocked at anything he said like I'm
shocked sometimes that we say would
something like this ever happen and most
of the time he goes yeah that happens
all the time that's sort of shocking
sometimes it beside that yeah I mean he
does have great stories that i think i
could say like you know going to china
and just he has to buy a separate phone
when he's there to use and then throw it
away when he leaves because the minute
your phone connects to a cell tower it's
automatically hacked and they can listen
to it when it's off and all this crazy
stuff like that i mean there's all kinds
of crazy stories you know but mostly
it's just great to have a guy like him
in the room
when we're writing who's you know and
it's just it's it's so funny like he ran
this huge company and he really enjoys
it seems it's experience was so recent
so it's amazing that he can reflect on
it reflect on me oh yeah comedic
elements to it yeah I think he just left
in June I would imagine it's it might be
therapeutic for him to just be able to
you know sort of pick through his
experience share it with people who are
how did it happen by the way how did you
reach out to him through kara swisher or
I could a DD I can't remember I just
remember hearing that he was out of a
job yeah I heard he's out of a job hubli
we arranged disaster important in a
while we orchestrated the whole thing
and now oddly enough in when we're done
with this season Alec will be the CEO of
Twitter oh my goodness what they said
Jack was permanent did they they did
make sure staffing lots not over yet